hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
[Music]
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u
garbage it's a little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
out they grew up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash oh yeah
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antony's basement
the sixers you [ __ ] stink you're
putting this woman through [ __ ] hell
two packs of new piece she did yesterday
two packs of new pies and two mortgage
payments
out the [ __ ] door because ben simmons
can't do a [ __ ] free throw
yeah but that's neither here nor there
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table
he's kind of the head big head around
here uh he's an international
businessman
so show him a little [ __ ] respect
give it up for kevin
james brian everybody
good to see you kelvin the three of us
all stood in the run like he's got the
biggest head he's in charge
biggest head biggest brain you do the
math there you go uh what's up gang
happy to be here
thanks for tuning in we [ __ ] love you
love you uh please make sure you
subscribe on itunes do it full video
available on youtube and as you know
sure
those numbers are true the roof true the
[ __ ] roof
i'm talking about cooking we're gonna
need a union roofer to get in here
do a couple of patches maybe redo the
whole thing a couple of no bed contracts
and then also uh obviously patreon.com
you sign up to patreon.com
are you garbage you don't even know the
bonus content you're getting
getting a whole other podcast it's
called hard feelings listen you get
bonus episodes of ayg we're doing weekly
we got fat court on there by the way my
cousin texted me he goes dude fat court
the way foley can lie is insane i feel
like it's like sitting across from a
serial killer
shout out to the hedgerow theater i feel
like i'm talking to the iceman
the classically trained liar jesus no
it's so
it's so apparent too yeah you think
you're lying but uh it's
it's you think we're buying it but we're
not do i
maybe you're lying uh and then also hard
feelings
so behind the curtains me and the big
man chopping it up we love it
it's like the hr it's the airing of the
grievances um
we got a lot of them around his dump
yeah so check that out as well
and then um uh live streams with the
patrons and also like
we have episode episodes stay there we
have episodes with the first episode
ever we did with our moms
we called [ __ ] we called denise and
patty played ayg with them
i mean we got me doing milk with dinner
we got there's so much [ __ ] on there we
have good stuff we have both cribs
episodes both cribs oh my childhood home
your childhood home got the limo got the
lim i mean
guys what are you doing sign up today
petrie and that came number one in
customer service
yeah all right number one in value and
that's passed on to you and your family
and in these trying times who couldn't
use a little extra money
there's no guarantee though all sales
are final
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire he's gearing up
for
that big weekend we're heading down to
ac if i can say that
keeping it evergreen oh man those shows
in ac were so good
yeah you're you're always so worried
about evergreen meanwhile you're talking
about the [ __ ] citrus game last night
this ain't coming until next week
out of the tournament we're [ __ ] the
week oh don't say that well let's say uh
then what time
i should be at my arraignment right now
in cape may county courthouse
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what's up dudes good to see you
al uh
had a [ __ ] amazing experience on the
train t-bone got recognized in the wild
for the first time
it's a good feeling right it's nice it
was nuts
hey are you the guy that [ __ ] up the
audio at my favorite new podcast
hey you the guy that won't shut up
don't know how to do jokes on air he
pulled a knife and was like hey if you
keep talking
yeah shout out to nick in connecticut
real nice guy shout out nikki he was on
the same train i was on that was
flooding
i saw that t-bone was taking on water on
a train you know you're hemmed up
i've never seen your trains guys no
dudes a couple tick tock kids got in the
bathroom rip some pipes out of the wall
really yeah the conductor came through
who opened up like the back
hatch to all where all the pumps are
looked at it just exhaled shook his head
and walked away
i'm in a union this don't fall under my
responsibilities you gotta love them
tick tock kids and if
from what i understand no cap we got a
hot new intern that has this on tick
tock
we do shout out yeah just check out uh
already garbage on tick tock shout out
to the bud light intern that's what
we've been calling them
bli good guy to bli bud light intern
professional professional wakeboarder
he does he's a beach guy really got a
good body on him body
tight body nice yeah very nice i on the
other hand
do not no shout out the fact whiteboard
shout out to fat court we have one more
episode today that we're recording this
is one more two more check-ins so this
is the this is the final check into fat
court and then
uh next week is the final weigh-in if
you're not on that patreon it is a
roller coaster we're having a good time
no that'll be out that'll be out this
weekend that you're hearing this
yeah but there's still one more check-in
oh that's out i guess
yeah okay yeah yeah
six flags is gonna buy us because this
thing's a [ __ ] roller coaster baby
a couple of swedes putting it together i
do want to i do i do need to make an
uh an apology cause i've been getting
[ __ ] beat up in the youtube comments
i know exactly what it's gonna be yeah i
made a joke in his lip
i made a joke off about our young cool
audience yeah uh i was trying to think
maybe he's teenagers i don't know trying
to make a joke i said only nobody under
32 listens or watches this show
which i know is factually false yeah our
bread and butter is
20s and 30s that's trending with the 18
to 25 demo
uh well maybe a couple especially after
my no cap t-shirt
well that's what i meant that's what the
joke came from i think but
literally you might you would have said
like i said you know told you to like
yeah that was the most divisive thing
i've ever said on here people like i'm
[ __ ] 20 you jerk off yeah yeah
you look 100 i'm like okay thanks i
apologize for that
um but shout out to all the young
listeners yeah tell those young kids to
steal their parents credit card by
goddamn helix mattresses
shout out to helix oh i don't know maybe
maybe next week
maybe shout out to helix next week
guys we're having fun here i would like
to formally apologize
i'm a man of principle when i found it
when i'm wrong i address it and say
i'm wrong thank you very much we
appreciate it i still think you're fat i
don't think i'm wrong about that i'm
going
yeah evidence uh points in all
directions that you're correct on that
some guy goes awesome kippy do you
forget that you're fat i'm like there's
a difference between 225 and four on
though okay
especially at the craps table nose wide
open yeah
gang we're back here with a family
episode it's just me the kipparino and
t-bone mcmuffin
uh we love you guys as you know when you
sign up for patreon
you'll get a question read on the air on
air on air
and that's what we're here to do today
we love you guys we appreciate all your
love and support
we're excited it's gonna be a great
summer man doing our thing
um yeah guys we [ __ ] love you if
you're coming out on the road we can't
wait to [ __ ]
we can't wait to meet listen we want to
meet this is so new like not to be corny
or whatever
this is also new for us so like if you
do see us in the street say what's up i
want to take like i want to [ __ ] talk
to everybody we need the human contact
yes let's have fun that's us three in
this [ __ ] studio
dodie who knows where the [ __ ] she is uh
but i can't wait to meet everybody
pictures the whole nine yards hanging
out
shaking hands kissing babies we love it
can't wait to meet everybody love it we
love it we love it
we will not stay at your place yeah a
couple people offered for me to uh
you know for us to stop by their place i
might
listen can i trade in my room voucher i
got a local guy i'm staying
for the young kid send pictures of the
man let's see what she looks like asking
me for a travel buyout
give me how much was my room returning
i'm staying with i'm staying with gary
in cincinnati
gary's mom's a hot piece what are you
gonna do what would it take for you to
stay with
a listener not much well yeah you're not
yeah
i don't know you say that though mm-hmm
but you're a specific kind of guy
i mean i would enjoy you know something
a little upscale
i mean if i uh no way you'd stay in a
place where stay comes into kool-aid
if i want run-of-the-mill i'll get out
of [ __ ] paddy's and [ __ ] do it up
down there
yeah you got to have some kind of
mcmansion it's got to be a three four
room house
multiple bathrooms i like my privacy
you can stay at our place you need to
remodel that after foley's done with it
yeah pool wouldn't be bad a mom that
knows how to cook
you know and keep her yap shut uh full
cable package of course
what are you moving in none of that
direct what are you signing a lease
what the [ __ ] a utility saying your name
right
what is included on this garage garage
fridge kids would be okay i love kids
you know what i mean
plus the snacks yeah not a bad look
that's good we'll see
we'll see me on the other hand i like my
i like my own domicile this guy's a real
germaphobe
i don't like i don't even like staying
in a buddy's place i'm like yo you hit
the bricks all right i'll get an airbnb
or something i'm not a couch guy
so unless you got a [ __ ] spare room
hit the bricks
and i don't mean a spare room like where
there's like a [ __ ] exercise bike in
there
an old treadmill with clothes on it yeah
maybe a helix
the twins offered me the keys to their
place cause they're gonna be out of town
when i'm in chicago they're like stay at
our place
so i might bring fleas back to the
studio no you're not staying with you're
not staying in the yurt or whatever the
[ __ ] those kids do
that ain't happening they're circus
fleas
step right up step right in look guys i
know it's weird but they're hard workers
ah jesus christ do you ever see a flea
on a trampoline toby's like hey the
bearded lady needs to do five minutes on
the first show in chicago
ah i can't wait to get the chat down
yeah it's gonna be a good one i'm having
a
couple of pops out there a couple of
pops
couple of pops good stuff yeah all right
let's get it let's get into it we got a
couple of [ __ ]
heaters and i i don't know if this one's
uh directed at me
but this is does it say dear jerk off
really durian sweeps week um all right
our contracts are up man yeah what are
you doing you're
[ __ ] going you bet coming at the king
you best not miss daddy you
um this is from peer review it just said
pyravine
pyravine sure i don't know why you're
heading me up on the pronunciation of
this name i'm clearly guessing i believe
it's peter but
it's pintner uh pierre yeah piravine
uh p-i-r-a-v-e-e-n
sounds classy yeah p-dog p-money i'm
calling go
p-money it just says dirt ball detector
how many syllables in the word
necklace is it necklace or necklace
i might throw a small a necklace i might
throw a small a in there
two two necklace necklace yeah yeah
which doesn't sound right when i say it
multiple times so i bought my mama
necklace you
say it but about my mom an emerald
necklace
you're trying you're tr i can hear you
trying to stick the landing on necklace
though
all right let me put myself in the
situation start screaming at me you
stupid [ __ ]
you fat piece of [ __ ] i bought you the
[ __ ] necklace didn't i yeah yeah
there you go yeah
i get but a big one in my family is
pocketbook
pack a book instead of pocketbook
pocketbook
first of all calling a person whether
you're saying pocketbook or pocketbook
that's trash pocketbook a pocketbook
there's like a story where my cousin was
like yeah can you
she was at college went away to college
for the first time she's like can you
grab my pocketbook
and the girl was like looking through
her room like what the [ __ ] is like
googling pocket i got no idea what the
[ __ ] he was talking about
yeah my pocketbook pocketbook's a big
one in my family
big huge that sounds like a book that
has like different skin ailments in it
what kind of pocket let me check my
pocketbook here that looks a little
discolored
that's trash calling it a pocketbook is
bad that's all denise calls it the same
thing
i think it's in my box what do you call
the vacuum cleaner
the vacuum the vacuum the vacuum cleaner
to me is trashy
it's the vacuum we call we would call it
the cleaner or the sweeper
get the sweeper oh no that's not right
no that's like
no uh that's like saying i'm watching
the tv
now you don't no good now yeah that's
that's a long time with clicker
you're just you're just calling it what
the function of it it clicks
and it sweeps by the way a sweeper would
be a broom one of my dad's chores
every day is to run this run the sweeper
on his people
and not too bad i might come over what
time what time are chores
you guys are real neat
[Laughter]
looking at the tv looking at the tv is
bad
i'm watching tv watching tv yeah clicker
is no good we've touched on that
but it's vacuum it's not a sweeper a
broom would be a sweeper
if you wanted to call something a
sweeper it's a broom it's definitely not
a vacuum
or a sucker or something get to sucker
my ex-girlfriend shows up get them
you guys know what they called in the uk
wait wait wait
call what the vacuum cleaner yep uh my
ex-girlfriend
i can think of a couple of words for
both uh what do they call a vacuum
cleaner in england
uh it's probably like a [ __ ] charlie
horse or something yeah
yeah something a little magical sitting
there put my peck in a charlie horse
[Laughter]
vacuum cleaner in england um
you're not gonna get this just tell us
what is it a
hoover oh that's bran hoover yeah we
were talking about getting a dice in the
other day
what yeah we're doing that well well
listen
now i know why the ad money hasn't
gotten here this guy's dabbling online
no so dyson yeah they make jet engines
i know dude i don't think so i mean
maybe yours
what airline do you flying it three on
dyson airplane
it's like saab saab makes [ __ ] jets
so does rolls royce they all make
engines and stuff yeah yeah pretty good
um uh yeah she was like well i think
about she's gonna die her friend's got
her friend in the building has one
and we got this like she you're in that
highfalutin building that's going to
cost
cause you got to keep up with the jones
i know yeah yeah
but she we bought one she don't the
broad don't like you're an electrolux
guy
the bro nah i do what the world does she
don't like spending money to get her to
spend money it's like the
bird she don't like spending she bought
this stuff that's why she's got it
she don't like spending i got to be like
yeah come on what do we do she like
what's a dyson these days couple hundy
yeah wow toby pull up a dyson a smaller
one because we live in an apartment the
only time i spend a couple of hundreds
was a cellophane bag
a couple of nosebeards catch my dress
give me a 30 rack and those beers call
it a nizei
talk about this call it a night in a
morning and an afternoon talk about the
hoover huh
look around to my nose dyson is tripping
bro
they're expensive dude for one without
even the
the fat receptacle just hold all the
gunk like the one in the handle probably
yeah the one that's like it's all up top
yeah it's like 700 bucks
700. no way no way i buy a used one
oh that's trash whatever dude dyson's a
dyson okay
pull up to the [ __ ] pull up to the
show with a dyson wait a second but the
one with the beach ball at the bottom
gives you all the maneuverability that's
only that's only five that doesn't make
any sense to me
this the thinner one is more expensive
yeah probably because rich people stop
yeah
you're not gonna be able to figure it
out i'm looking at your knees right now
i know uh yeah
and shoulders for some reason
basketball shorts onstage i got fresh
cargos on did you ever wear those
basketball shorts on stage by the way no
show got canceled oh that's right
oh man i was on that show with you yeah
oh i would
let you have it um
i just work it into a bit whatever i got
robbed though
he's still gonna flush it out these
bozos eat it up
um we're thinking i don't because right
now we just got like a
25 30 dollar john that we got because we
were like hemmed up cash
25. yeah it stinks we literally did a
test where it was like it threw like a
piece of hair on the ground like a piece
of paper and you're just [ __ ] right
over it
who did that what do you mean you did
that at the house house i'm like this
thing's
there you meant like the showroom or
something no we ordered it on [ __ ]
amazon bestseller or something i thought
you were at the vacuum cleaner
convention
did you did you guys have a dust buster
growing up yeah and a dirt devil
the dirt devil was nice that's just a
vacuum cleaner no the handheld plug
like the powerful thing really yeah this
thing would [ __ ]
it could eat it we had the dirt the dust
buster
then we had the big power john we
weren't a dust buster family i always
wanted one
no not gonna happen wall mounted at the
ryan's
wall mounted on the wall oh no no
no no single mom's not mounting that on
the wall
this was in the front closet she's too
busy getting mounted herself huh
you hear that mom you hear that he
walked into that denise
on your dirty floor i don't know what to
tell you what are you talking about we
got
a dirt devil ain't no dirty floors
around we had a cleaning lady too nice
shout out to esther and then denise the
dirt devils fully calls his dick
i almost made that joke 30 seconds ago
and i didn't do it so i couldn't give it
to you
thank god i chose not to do it
what was the question ah i forget oh
necklace pocketbook
yeah pocketbook dyson somehow we got
there yeah
um yeah so am i i mean not for seven
hundo i ain't becoming a dice
dyson those fans are nice that they have
though that bladeless domes
i don't know how that works do i i don't
know what happens i'm so
i don't know trashy i don't know if it's
trashy or what it is but that to even
like
have i would never even price that out
what do you mean that bladeless fan i
just go well i'm not a
i'm not bladeless fan people no i'm a
i'm a [ __ ] boxer
he's a box fan one of the one of those
round ones
they're selling it at a drugstore that's
right that's what i do
know where to get a [ __ ] that's what
i'm saying like i don't know if it's
just i'm so
[ __ ] we would never spend money on
that
you got to go to like harry's and
sonomas or something like that harry's
in sonomas chaplain is called william
and sonomas oh him too yeah it's good
good guys you guys are all right you
gotta go somewhere classy
yeah i don't know um well [ __ ] seven
hundo for a dicing
[ __ ] that it's getting electrolytes
happening this one's
this one's a [ __ ] home run oh this is
another thing growing up i wanted to ask
talking on vacuums did you have the
proper one with the bag or did you have
the little container that follows you
around
obviously the classiest one that was in
the walls that was the classiest version
of yeah
my neighbor but that was for a limited
time in the 90s
on home control i call it with my peepee
and that thing
had a couple of sleepovers guys [ __ ] on
the wall again yeah
um no we had uh we were an electrolux
family i believe door-to-door
i think someone got their hooks with my
mom early all right and then we were we
saw that bro come in a mile away we were
electrolux but no we had the uh
we had the base this is the 80s like the
like the packet like the box
with the with the tube did a handle oh
it was a
it looked like a like a wiener dog like
a huge wiener dog
had a wheels on it and it had a tube and
then it went up into the thing that that
that vacuumed
it wasn't a one piece it is now if at
any point a door-to-door salesman has
stepped foot in your house you are from
garbage stocks yeah oh we've been a
couple never a couple of guys that's old
that was
that was 80s still that wasn't really
around in the 90s i remember we had one
guy
that got there like right before my dad
came home and we he was [ __ ] working
my mom over in the living room
and my dad came
love you patty but this is a lava i'm
sure he was
it's my job i got to make it he was
working her over and delivering a doggy
or what are we talking about
he was actually very gentle throwing
that dirt double at her
i heard his hair came back there you go
ah my dad walked in and was like you
out meatloaf table now i got it all i
used to do i told you i used to do the
door-to-door sell
windows siding and roofing did you ever
close a deal
i wasn't a closer i would get them
interested in sending the closer out
i'd be like yeah listen you know it's
real cheap you were the kid that went
around and smashed all the windows
no that no no no you need one not use
can't leave
uh i would i was like the marketing guy
would go around and then like i would be
like
you know marketing yeah well that no
that's what it was
no so we would send the canvassers out
right these like derelict delinquent
kids
you know send them out they knock on the
doors and they go and i would be in the
neighborhood and be like hey i got i
think i got a live one here
i would go qualify the lead to find out
if it was like
good or not you might be like hey how
long you been looking this or that have
you have any other quotes
because then you're just in the
neighborhood yeah in a minute i called
it cops on all these
hard pap and a couple of times so
i would go qualify the lead to be like
okay this is worth sending a salesman
out to otherwise like you know because
then the salesman gets out there and
they're in for blood
they get out there big they're a real
[ __ ] oh dude like 48 grand to get your
windows done i'm like it's a [ __ ]
trailer park you bozo that guy's not
spending 48 grand to get his windows
done
hit the [ __ ] bricks that's trash
on the same one this is from omar do you
have a no trespassing sign in your front
yard
that and a beware dog sign be where a
dog we've done is bad but a no
trespassing why did you ever be wearing
a dog no i'm saying we've done on the
show
not too long ago no trespassing sign or
a no solicitor sign is always tough too
yeah that's i don't even know what
solicitor meant i thought it was some
kind of italian
um are they the darker ones from the
south
no sicilians no sicilians um the
beware of dog sign and not having a dog
is trash the no trespassing
was just so uninviting who's going near
your house
yeah it's like you're not that important
to begin with yeah we never had any of
those things i hated that stuff
now i'm not saying my mom didn't steal a
[ __ ] adt sticker
from the [ __ ] guy doing a job next
door sure put it in the window to
[ __ ] keep people on their toes
yeah yeah yeah there was no cameras yeah
i picked up
no system yeah just a dog um
that's funny yeah no we were never i
also i think in the 90s that stopped the
coming on like that that was big in the
80s the door-to-door or
[ __ ] the 90s was more catalogues
i don't know can't do it now with kovy
now gang this episode is brought to you
by our good friends over there at
stamps.com the best the best
the best you know who wants to wait in
line at the post office
not me stuff's opening back up you want
to get out there got things to do
you got bbqs you got movies gotta hit
the pool the beach
hit the pool the not waiting in line use
stamps.com
we use them we love them they've helped
out thousands and thousands of small
businesses all across the country
and save them tons and tons of money
they get special rates special deals
with usps and ups and you don't got to
go anywhere
know it all right from your office or
home
yeah guys uh it brings the same us
postal and ups
uh shipping services right to you from
your computer all you need is a computer
a printer and the internet i don't care
if you got a house a car
an office whatever you got you can print
official us postage shipping labels 24 7
without ever having to leave your desk
or buy any fancy equipment all you need
is a computer a standard printer
once it's ready you can drop it in the
mail they can come pick it up we do it
we use we send out all the cards and all
the merch that way
it's easy peasy they sent us the setup
the printer about a bing it just prints
it out i feel yeah i feel like i work at
ups or something it's a good time
it's nice i feel official you got the
print you
lick it and stick it even puts on the
brown shirt and the shirt
pulls the socks up uh yeah guys it's a
no-brainer uh they offer deals you can't
get anywhere else like 40
of you you usps and up to 66
off ups uh so rates
wasting time go to the post by going to
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
garbage you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial
uh plus a free postage and digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
now code bozos go to stamps.com click
the promo code to
click the microphone at the top of the
home page type in garbage at stamps.com
promo code garbage
do it gang real quick let's talk about
one of our favorite sponsors
fume mm-hmm we know we love them
canadian-made a wooden inhaler with the
power of super plants
okay no chemicals no
electronics just all natural relaxation
all right great great great nicotine
alternative yeah
great for allergies yeah it's good stuff
great stuff you know what they told the
chemicals what they tell them
kick rocks hit the bricks yeah hey we
don't want you we don't need
chemicals you got rocks kick em all
match around it feels nice in your hand
too it's good quality
good quality canadian made wood yeah let
me see that thing it's good it's good
for the oral fixation the hand to mouth
type thing you get to pull on something
it's not a vape
there's no harmful chemicals nicotine
nothing uh they they're conquer cure uh
it's the name of the
cure that they use for it's the number
one quitting smoking from start to
finish
they taste great uh they got a minty
earthy taste sweet
a little bit of sweetness mixed in there
black pepper tell them about the black
oh a little bit of bread a little bit of
black pepper nicotine cravings
eases the nicotine cravings pepper
peppermint in there for the cooling a
little menthol
menthol kick you know what i mean and
lavender to ease the pain of quitting
lower the shoulders a bit take the edge
it's all about taking the edge off
that's what it is and that's what they
do so head to breathefume.com
check out their quit naturally pack it
comes with one fume and two packs of
conquer cures to get you on your journey
to breathing free of addiction
the link's going to be in the bio make
or the description make sure
you let them know you're using uh by
using our promo code garbage for 10
off your uh entire order today
uh one more time that's breathefume.com
breathefumefum.com
click the link in the description use
promo code garbage
quit smoking and vaping today now back
to the show
um all right this one's from uh casey
did you ever have a pringles tupperware
container in your lunchbox
the fact that you refer to pringles you
refer to it as pringles tupperware
is a tough look i know what you're
talking about what do you but i don't
know what
like that pringles tube it looks like a
pringles tube but it's plastic
it's four pringles oh the stack yeah oh
i thought you meant like one of these
i'm like what are you putting a hoagie
in there
what the [ __ ] would take that to like
[ __ ] pull it out
like your nicholas cage in the rock
cut by the way kids had those the
stackers and it was like a two-piece
like a
yeah gotcha no none of that [ __ ] there
was none of that stuff
yo listen the only way you take pringles
to lunch is in the small
can if you're putting pringles in a bag
they ain't lasting who's getting those
though
growing up in the 90s they were big you
would get a [ __ ]
small thing of pringles yeah i wouldn't
kids would would you go to school
buckingham palace pat would roll up with
that
really and pat was a big dunkaroos
family too mom would never my mom would
never buy dunk
dude he was also the first person that
had like a proper pantry
or you walk into it right like it's not
just like you've been to my mom's world
it's like the door opens and it's like
recessed in it let me taste it
you say what you want about the piece
and her personal life and how she
conducts herself
but that pantry is top [ __ ] shelf we
could go there right now
be satisfied she got a lot of good stuff
in there my mom
yeah and actually that pantry was all
right well she got the kids she's got
the kids there for all the [ __ ]
snacks
and she'll splurge on him she didn't
splurge on us wow my [ __ ] niece and
nephew
when my parents picked him up from
school they have [ __ ] snacks waiting
for him
[ __ ] this and that that she's buying
movies for him she just dropped [ __ ]
20 or 30 on cruella
the other night wait is that never
that's another thing i want to talk
about is that a thing
i remember when on demand came out and
to watch like the 24 hour rental
on demand it was like it was 399 or
something 499
was the first you could rent a new
release or whatever not like proper new
but like when it got to on demand
let me explain so it was 4.99 if that if
i did that when i was home from college
if i put a 499 charge oh i would be
beaten oh dude
i would get a phone call because you
wouldn't get it for like two weeks later
i would get phone calls did you watch uh
you know what i mean like
[ __ ] whatever and i'm like yeah like
what are you i'm like i'll give you the
four bucks
no and you can give me 50 i'll give you
i'm still conditioned when i go home my
wife was like oh let's watch a movie i'm
like because we were home and nobody was
there
i'm like okay and i'm like i'm gonna get
a phone call about this
my mom would look over that cable bill
like it was a [ __ ] legal document
yeah like lit like she was [ __ ] ally
mcbeal looking over this [ __ ] thing i
don't know any of these girls but did
they go wild or not
[Laughter]
yeah never ne if you if you stepped
anywhere outside the basic cable plan
now you were [ __ ] you were getting
screened putting your life in your hands
oh never never but now they're [ __ ]
whatever they want yeah now that they
understand i think they didn't they
understand it a little bit more
you know what i wanted to talk to you
about what was that big man uh
belveda cookies do you know what i'm
talking about
yes wait but i i know that i know the
name and i know i can see the name
written i can't stress this enough the
belveda
blueberry crisp is one of the crackers
no
they're i don't know what to do they're
like i think they're like [ __ ] fiber
crackers or breakfast
breakfast bars or something this is
their cookies this is mom and kid [ __ ]
this ain't for me dude i'm telling you
right now they blow your [ __ ] hair
back they are
unbelievable no i'm telling you give it
a shot
you'll be in here apologizing again i
got a question for you sure
i was just down the shore last week okay
they went to the house
uh-huh if you're doing like sliced
cheese at the house for like an app or
whatever
you'd like you know like pepperoni
cheese and pep like a meat plate like a
meat cheese and meat
sure what kind of cheese are they doing
it's not slices it's not big squares for
sandwiches
no you [ __ ] ass it's cracker barrel
chop-chop already chopped
no no that's what i did there was a
stack of them at the crib
no [ __ ] it's trashy
but there's no middleman daddy oh
there's no there's no leg work to get
that cooking
you get a piece of [ __ ] pepperoni or
in a [ __ ] stacey's pita chip
i could go to the night cracker balor's
like a [ __ ] yeah
like around the ar-15
you better be johnny on the spot with
the cracker barrel yeah
now i've i know what you're talking
about that's more costco big bulk kind
of [ __ ] no
no no no it's like this big it's like
the square cracker barrel thing
already sliced i don't like that because
i like i don't hate it
i like to do my own thickness these are
thicker
than what you would typically do yeah
they got a little bit of density doing i
don't like that
nothing wrong with a little try give it
away all i'm saying give it a whirl try
the velveeta
i can't they're too fibery looking i'm
telling you man they got like [ __ ]
blades of wheat on the front i'm not the
cracker brand
no thanks yeah what's it called what are
they what are they officially called
your blueberry john's yeah no belvita
it's not like cookie or cracker it's
uh belvita crackers
maybe they're biscuits biscuits yeah
salt
no i'm telling you that's like that's
like the [ __ ]
not vitamix or whatever that you're
like that's like [ __ ] they look like
women's it looks like it's just for
older ladies these boxes
i'm not doing it can't do it keep your
estrogen up yeah it's [ __ ] like that
two boxes of those you got a set of
double d's
and you're post-menopausal while we're
talking food i had this thought
yesterday i wanted to get your guys
opinion on this is there a more
garbage fast food establishment than the
combination
kfc taco bell the slash is known in my
in some circles is the slash
kfc slash taco bell damn that's fire the
baskin robbins dunkin donuts ain't no
[ __ ]
uh michelin star restaurant either we
used to have a couple of those in a
family
owning them yeah oh my god couple of the
franchises
you owned a dunkin donuts not me
personally but a guy
i'm aware of that fade a killing dude
[ __ ] yeah and [ __ ] my
my problem was and for for those out
there that don't is is baskin robbins an
uh
a worldwide organization i think it's
nationwide
okay it's nice it's an ice cream if not
tonight it's an ice cream joint 31
flavors
was the thing
when they started working with dunkin
donuts it's like eight flavors and they
it's it's the same bozo that has to work
both and they never want to [ __ ] with
the baskin robbins
forget about getting a sample it's like
you're asking for a kidney
it's [ __ ] trash and you would think
that they would mix it up like they
would do like a
like a iced coffee ice cream float or
something
toby i couldn't agree more you would
think you were making that
donuts and ice cream okay give me a
glaze and a scoop of rocky road [ __ ]
a
i don't know a [ __ ] donut sandwich
something i gotta [ __ ] think of this
dress you know they're doing that for
themselves
oh my god i might i'm sure i've said
this on the podcast
but donut stinks by the way their coffee
sucks everything else is pretty good
they know their way around a hash brown
that's the only thing they got good
dunkin donuts in new york
[ __ ] stink also those people working
the the counter at the slash
they got to be whipping up all type of
fried chicken taco
i would be doing that i always said the
only reason i would ever want to work at
a fast food place is to make my own
stuff
i would have like a big mac mcmuffin we
talked about this so we got the
i believe that's how we got to make
foley uh shout out to torielli picks
gotcha if you've ever worked at a
combination kfc taco bell please tell us
the [ __ ] you were slapping together it's
gotta be pretty bonkers i would assume
but also a lot of times when you're
around that food you don't like eating
it that much nashville hot chicken hot
chicken chalupa dude
i'm sure it gets old you see once you
see how the sausage is made
no thank you that's true uh
great question all right this was from
james alguber
uh kids are clever with
the names what do you want with american
all goobers
uh ever had cereal for all three meals
now when i i'm i don't i feel like
you're the same
i get in the never ending bowl of cereal
predicament if i open up i'm a big
special k guy
love special k well it's a bare bone
cereal good
classic [ __ ] dump some whole milk in
there
[ __ ] up the roof of your mouth though
it'll get you it'll [ __ ] tear you
it's like eating firecrackers
that captain crunch like broken glass
but
i'm crushing that box right like in a
sitting for the most part
i'm doing like [ __ ] 19 000 calories
right away
i if i open a box it never really it's
not gonna last till dinner
i'm gonna like i'm not gonna be able to
have the same serving i have in the
beginning that i'm gonna have in the end
i'd have to have like three boxes of
cereal on hand for that you know what i
mean
yeah that makes sense i'm not a cereal
as a meal kind of guy
even breakfast now when i was a little
kid sure but i don't look at cereal now
as a meal that's an in between more of
an appetizer that's an in-between snack
i think we're getting to the root of the
problem here
that's it like you know that's it like
okay the way i would do cereal would be
if i'm ordering breakfast from
from the deli i'm gonna get an omelette
i'm gonna get a couple of english
muffins i'm gonna get the home fries
and then i'm gonna get give me a box of
[ __ ] reese's puffs
and then after like an hour of having
the omelet i'm gonna start
that's that's in between that's that's a
treat
that's not i don't use that as a meal a
bowl of cereal isn't a meal for me
and it would be multiple bowls this year
yeah yeah we've touched on this on the
show before but you got to go for the
dirtbag acai bowl
toss a little scoop of peanut butter on
the side of that little bite and sip
mentality it's
a little bit of peanut butter every bite
it's a game
changer i'm i i mean i haven't had the
last time i see it was the very
beginning of the pandemic
i actually i haven't had in a long time
either it's just such a waste of like
i'm trying
obviously trying to eat better and stuff
so it's like i'm not gonna sit down and
have like [ __ ]
three four bowls of cereal you know what
i mean i'm like i'd rather
i'd rather get my i'd rather have that
i'd rather drink beers at night than do
that you know what i mean
yeah i was looking for a bowl of cereal
at my mom's house last weekend to be
honest with you
came up dry really yeah boneless she's
she's she's running a tight tight chip
down there no bread
the only bread they have is this protein
bread that's in the freezer
that you'd rather eat a pack of [ __ ]
baseball cards and [ __ ]
that's tough that might the broad does
that too it's like
it's actually german bread that they
sell here it's like
it looks like a brick it's like an air
dryer i'm talking about i know exactly
like fiber x or something that's not
that bad it's not
bad it's not bad when it's like you
gotta do
something to it you bite one of those
it's like it's a brittle you know it
like falls up
crumbles it ain't easy to eat you gotta
[ __ ] hit it with a torch or something
let me ask you this you ever been hemmed
up no milk and had to improvise
a serial liquid substitute no the cereal
goes back in the [ __ ] box yeah and i
call it i call dominance
that's crazy to me we're not even going
down that road that's nuts i don't want
to hear about you and your [ __ ] a
w mini weeds all right
yogurt oh sure yeah i mean come on
that's a [ __ ] meat that's a dick but
you can't put [ __ ] cocoa puffs and
[ __ ] people
we've gotten that question a lot and
some it's like hey you ever use
water it's like nah that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of here bonkos
that's hooverville [ __ ] yeah no way i'm
a [ __ ] gentleman i'm gonna spend my
last 10 bucks on delivery okay
now not since the new deal's been signed
um
this one's pretty good this is from
matthew uh new to patreon
is it garbage to fall asleep in public
like in a waiting room or an airport
terminal or something like that
a waiting room is a tough look if you're
nodded off in a waiting room dude the
head bob too it's like you're on
oxycontin you're [ __ ] going down and
coming up going down and coming up
that's bad
it ain't good yeah i fell asleep on the
set a few weeks ago
like around people oh yeah you always
you wake up you feel so
vulnerable you start looking i can hear
myself snoring and it wakes me up so i
know i must have been snoring for at
least five minutes before
really yeah [ __ ] those naps though
you're never more tired yeah it's like
sitting in church
it's just the sleep is just so enticing
remember falling asleep in school
i made a living and falling asleep in
high school oh i never fell asleep in
high school
what put your head down on your desk and
[ __ ] crank out no
oh my god you sleep like an angel
uh-uh oh never did that i don't think
that actually you always wake up a
little bit and you feel like the drool
on your lips
yeah no oh i used to love too vulnerable
i got my [ __ ] head on a swivel i
can't be caught [ __ ]
literally sleeping just christ no yeah
i don't know who's after me but they
ain't gonna [ __ ] catch me slipping
tell you that much
check your [ __ ] six it's a
school that's the school i come from
step one check yourself would you go to
school step two check your six again
they might be [ __ ] serpent's lurk
okay would you go to school top gun
no playing around yeah man i don't like
sleeping in public
i don't even like sleeping
we used to do those those late night
movies a few years ago with all the
comedians would go for like the big
releases
and some of those i would [ __ ] nod
out of because they were like the
midnight showings or 12 35 showings
i was up for [ __ ] work at seven or
eight o'clock
then work all day comedy all night spots
or whatever
then go to that and by like [ __ ] you
know midway through the first act i'm
[ __ ]
sleeping in a movie theater is the
[ __ ] best i know but then i'm also so
mad
but i'm like i got a [ __ ] weak plot
line i'm out yeah but that but then that
ride home at [ __ ] 2 30 a.m it's like
you're leaving the bar you're like all
[ __ ] i'm like i wish i just would
have stayed home and slept this one off
or just
finished the night out in the theater
wake up catch your matinee and bounce
you're at the concession saying what do
you guys have for breakfast
you have any french toast back there
guys do pancakes to order oh ma'am
uh this is from eric uh did you ever
have to go to work with your parents as
a kid my son's with me all week because
daycare is true to [ __ ] roof
we've touched on that i was a big go to
work with the big go to work with my dad
and my mom my mom worked in a hospital i
went with her sometimes
so just hanging out in the lab you're
making rounds
holy [ __ ] this guy ain't gonna make it
hey buddy's your wife here i got to talk
to her uh i went
i would every once in a while you
thought about getting your affairs in
order
um but my pop was in the navy when i was
when i was little and he was stationed
that uh you want an aircraft carrier
i'm launching f-14 you got the headset
with the [ __ ] things
these russians ain't playing around that
fat kid's out on the deck again
um two parts to that my dad so every
once in a while it wasn't because of
daycare whatever maybe it was
we never went to like proper daycare no
no nobody ever paid for my supervision
no that was never that was never on the
table
no it was my brother they would put me
in a kennel before
before i was going to something like
that it was an aunt
my aunt mary katherine watched me when i
was growing up it was [ __ ]
she did it with a few different
generations but for a while
like my me and my brother are two years
apart but for some reason i don't know
where the [ __ ] he went
uh if he was maybe already like in
kindergarten or something like that
but i remember i was with my aunt mary
catherine [ __ ] in wilkes-barre
every day for like you know a year or
two and we had our routine i'd get there
she'd have my snack ready
i'd have the box of toys that her sons
left you know because they were like
five years older sure she would do her
chores and [ __ ] like that
would ship it over to [ __ ] 12 o'clock
mass at holy saver
come back [ __ ] lunch she'd start
working on
dinner holy savior sorry which she'd
start working sounds like it
sounds like a religious [ __ ]
supermarket
holy savory come on down to the holy
saver
the price of christ compels you
sail so good you'll burn in hell
no she would start dinner i'd watch my
cartoons do my thing it was [ __ ]
heaven it was paradise yeah it was
unbelievable
um so never was i ever getting any
that does suck now i know my buddy who
has a kid now
he's like yeah [ __ ] daycare's like
[ __ ] 10 g's
yeah or something like that well yeah i
never trust those places
well what might my especially the ones
in the city you ever drive by one you're
like that's a [ __ ]
nurse that's where [ __ ] daycare is
going on well my sister my sister's got
a pretty good
my sister and her kids got a pretty good
deal there's like a girl in the
neighborhood
who's like they've run it out of the hat
it's i don't know it's not like
commissioned
but it's this girl that they've known
for years like people have like she's
like older she's probably like
50 or something nancy or amy or
something
and she just has like the neighborhood
like she watches the kids in the
neighborhood and i don't know how much
it is
nancy's daycare and dog fighting
let me get a sawbuck on the little
blonde i don't like that dude you can't
be sending your kids to an off the books
daycare yeah
it's more of a babysitter you know what
i mean
i can't dude you've had to appear this
before you've never heard of that
no that's crazy under the table get out
of here
yeah for sure it's a babysitter a
babysitter comes to your house
okay but that's how it started it was
like oh i can babysit your kids or
whatever and then it was like
hey when they're going back to school
like i'm having
the smiths and the stevensons are
sending their two youngest that aren't
going to school over
and i'll watch the three of them type
thing
good you can't drop your kids off
somewhere there's a cash only sign
i think she takes venmo yeah now i was
at aunt mary kay's [ __ ]
chilling yeah like a villain but on
special occasions not out of necessity
but my dad the one place he was
stationed when i was young was uh was a
voca
air station a revoking naval base which
is in the middle of wilkes-barre i don't
know what the [ __ ] was going on but
there was
there wasn't ship one i could tell you
that yeah
i was a recruiting station because
that's my dad that he was a recruiter
we'd go there every once in a while and
that was like a [ __ ]
that was like a treat there was like a
torpedo in the lobby and like they would
have like national guard trucks and [ __ ]
like that running it out of there
[ __ ] commissary it was [ __ ] nice
but my mom worked at the gap
back in the day at the wyoming valley
mall
and i remember like legit going to work
with her
and like hanging out like in the storage
room
and like me and my brother would get to
like run around the mall a little bit
that's why i saw a return to the jedi
for the first time shout out to it
um but i remember like legit just being
in the store
and like hanging on my mom while she was
like dealing with customers
could you imagine could you imagine
today
hanging out at the gap no could you
imagine you're trying to make a purchase
at a [ __ ] clothing store
and you're [ __ ] you're trying to
you're bringing your booger reader he's
[ __ ] running around yeah
i got caught stealing from her at that
gap a pair of chinos
patty your kid has three pairs of pants
on right now
15 shirts no i took money out of her
purse for a song i was stealing from her
yeah oh yeah
yeah i did it a couple times a couple of
times i remember being in like a lot
because my mom was like uh
she worked in the lab at hospitals and
doctors all i remember the lab you were
in the lab
yeah i was in places i probably would
you have like a [ __ ] uh a scrub suit
on
no like that i had my [ __ ] dc t-shirt
on my skateboard you weren't like one of
the dudes in the wuhan lab with like a
[ __ ]
space like homer who got the who got the
gummy bears and the blood samples
yeah um that was that was always that
wasn't a lot
but my dad owned his own company so that
was that's a little different yeah
can't say nothing yeah i mean yeah you
running around the shop is one thing
yeah i used to ride my mini bike indoors
and they would get so mad
oh my god shout out to the mini bike big
head little [ __ ]
yeah waiting for the lunch truck
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry miss we did everything we
could but the surgery was not
i'm not in the hospital
it was the same dirt bike from dumb and
dumber that he trades the kids straight
up cash
or straight up in town trades the van
same one the hog we used to call it
going right into the emergency room
watching me do a figure eight mom but
that was always fun
obviously i mean people get hemmed up
[ __ ] like i said that shit's
expensive you do what you gotta do yeah
yeah yeah like using off the books lady
in the neighborhood
[Laughter]
welcome to the underground railroad
daycare we have to leave at dusk
that's [ __ ] shifty but she's also
good that my mom's watching the kids
like full-time
she's got my brother's kid she's got my
sister's stuff and i'm like that's what
you need you need a support system and i
i know it's funny i think she's tapping
out a bit though i think she's going yo
oh i'm sure [ __ ] i'm like she's now
six kids in
you got c you have six they each have
three jesus christ yeah she's been
watching [ __ ] kids for the past
decade yeah no [ __ ] she's in her [ __ ]
golden years yeah she's trying to get it
in and get it out but
you know what i mean no i don't
[Laughter]
no i do not henry why don't you explain
t-bone time stamp this i'm going to send
her this clip
i get that vibe too that my mom wishes
she was stepping out a little bit
she's hemmed up she's busy yeah deals
with the kids all that kind of stuff
yeah watch i wouldn't i'd be like
[ __ ] here's money go forget daycare
or something put them in the after
school program oh there you go the piece
could do that she's got the flex
she's talking about getting away too
talk about florida really getting away
not moving yeah uh i would hate that i
could no i would never want to be what
if i get that house
oh there you go teddy's too too
south whoa now we're talking i'm talking
about the one they live in now
yeah yes to turn a proper basement into
hoodies
game room pool table i don't know if you
can make the turn
that was always the big problem with
that basement tough getting guests down
there though
yeah uber um all right let's see
[Laughter]
um all right this is from publish
publishing uh do you rinse off your
fruit before you eat it
i'm a i have to i mentally i need to
rinse kind of anything i
i do i know what i'm supposed to say
that you eat fruit
[Laughter]
do you wash off your pringles um
i wash my chicken i don't do that and i
found out you shouldn't do that i never
did that growing up
i wash everything chicken salmon but why
are you why do you think you're washing
chicken it's all slimy
yeah but you're cook people say you
should wash chicken which i don't
[ __ ] get because it's like
not with soap and water i just rinse it
with water and then i put it in the
dishwasher
it comes out comes out [ __ ] medium
throw a tide pod in there
um they're saying so you shouldn't you
shouldn't
it's also because it creates more of a
[ __ ] mess now you have wet now that
yeah yeah it's like you have salmon
everywhere it's like now that's all over
the [ __ ] that's why they invented lysol
wipes
via the cdc do not wash raw chicken
during washing chicken juices can spread
in the kitchen
and contaminate other foods yeah i'm not
i'm washing my chicken i don't like that
slime we never did growing up and then
to my wife was like you got to wash it
and she makes me wash it i'm like get
out i'm not washing the chicken because
then i'm the one drying it
she don't like touching it then it's on
my hands i'm i'm like i'm not doing
i'm if you want me to do it i'm doing it
the way i do it i'm not doing it the way
you do it
my once if you want to do it you do it
my one friend's mom wouldn't dr uh wash
it but she would have it dry cleaned and
we'd
hanger steak extra starch not bad
not bad at all kippy is about to
choke on his water man you got me right
at the
right at the perfect time um fruit i
yeah i watch everything i don't i don't
cause i was getting yelled at cause i
didn't watch uh
wash uh doughnut peach you know what a
donut peach is
it's always donuts with you even your
fruit
you ever had an angel food apple [ __ ]
angel food cake that stuff sucks
that fluffy [ __ ] can i get some brownie
bananas ah brutal
no uh doughnut uh peaches they're
delicious they're in season right now
too
now i never wash anything i should i
hate when you start with your underwear
i hate like grapes grapes look really
dirty i'm allergic to grapes
as i got older i'm allergic to the skin
how do you drink wine it's got to be
processed
it's got to be processed yeah man same
thing with
carrots carrots the skin and you have to
there's a protein
in this just started probably like maybe
five years ago
there's a protein in the raw produce
skin that i get it's [ __ ] my [ __ ]
throat starts itching my [ __ ]
yeah my asthma kicks in head swells up
eyebrows get back swells up pee pee gets
small
i've been suffering for years i think i
got that too uh yeah it's a tough look
dude the one time my wife was like yeah
[ __ ] skit do something with the
carrot and like
i got in the air and then i was breathed
dude i looked like my eyes swelled up my
[ __ ]
my throat was it was a tough look look
at how beat up
oh man yeah so i gotta boil my carrots
before i eat them
really yeah tough guys i know
i know toby cut that boil your cow i'm
not
proud i got too much too much work on my
hands cutting myself out of this episode
all right this is from miller lite30 and
i do not condone this first time
question
ever refer to the length of a car ride
by how many beers you can drink on the
ride
as in that ride out the wild what is it
at least a six beer ride
i don't con i don't agree with this and
i'm happy with the
changes to drinking and driving we've
made since the 80s and 90s
which seemed looking back lawless
i don't know if that was just the
circles i was operating in as an
eight-year-old
uh it just seemed a lot of parents
[ __ ] drove a lot of open containers
a lot you know i remember the one time i
was talking to my dad i'm like yeah i'm
going to the mall he's like no drinking
and driving i'm like are you drinking on
the way i
wonder why your outfits stink
i wonder why you're dressed like a
[ __ ] jerk off you're drunk at macy's
sweatpants and button down
penny's all boozed up i'm looking for
deals
don't be drinking on the way to the mall
it's crazy yeah no
no drinking and driving i don't do it i
don't do it i don't condone it
i'm doing it stop it that and the seat
belt my dad put the fear of god into us
when we were
oh we seat belts were dorks if you
really never
never what my dad would make me do it in
the front seat
if we were like young he was also played
if i was also at the age where they were
like hey if you're under 12 i was
already
in the front seat as a kid and then they
were like yeah kids under 12 shouldn't
be that front seat i was like seven i'm
like do we have to listen to that he's
like
there'd be times hop in the back if we
were like pulling up to a checkpoint or
if a copper would have hop in the back
because i wasn't allowed in the front
jesus christ yeah you ever you ever pull
the
the hold the wheel as a kid
is seven-year-olds all [ __ ] drunk
over here picking them up from the bar
mahoney's i'm thinking i'm home
i can't get this kid to dry out
yeah they'll take you to foster care but
they ain't taking me to jail yeah
it was uh yeah steer holding the wheel
that was
holding the wheels out here grab the
wheel
yeah nothing makes me feel more than my
dad when i'm reaching for money
while i'm driving and you got to do this
i say to my wife like if i grab the
wheel i gotta you know what i mean
now i got the easy pass i reaching for
cage no more which by the okay that's
more of a hard feelings we'll get in it
i got a [ __ ]
bone to pick with the easy pass really
and the nypd
making you pay your bill [ __ ] dude
tune into the next hard feelings i got
some
[ __ ] to say i yelled at a [ __ ] ticket
guy yesterday
really we'll get into a little teaser a
little epitheaser
yeah [ __ ] whatever
moving forward this is from dylan have
you ever let us sit
a sig backwards in front of someone you
were trying to impress
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you up man give you a
headache yeah i've done it
walking out on a deck after about eight
or nine beers it's dark out you're not
you're like
a little too drunk and you're like
selling hands you're talking it's always
the talk before the light
you get disoriented right in your mouth
you don't realize what way it's turned
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] get a stinger there's a sub
question to that
have you ever had to smoke that
cigarette after you've torched it
no i always i've done it where it's my
last sig and i'm like this is out of a
bad movie
like i'm like i just smoked my last cig
backwards
no i've also been really drunk at this
kid justin's house in high school
and just that house particularly
what no this is where this is one time
okay one time i was there really
you got drunk there frequently we did i
mean it was i don't know i don't know
where his parents were but
it was a it was a it was one it was a
town
houses it was a town house single mom
townhouse
where you could get in from the back
like the front
it was on a hill like so the front was
like street level but then it had an
exposed basement like a sliding door to
the basement so you can get out
i don't know why you're looking at me so
inquisitively you're like
i'm gonna try to wrap your head around a
basement that you can walk out of yeah
most
yeah that's normal no most basements are
underground
i understand what you're saying though
we we had a you could get out of our
our first house you can get out through
the basement okay yeah
okay i don't know sure yeah i don't know
architectural uh no you were just giving
me a look like you didn't understand
what i was saying and then went yeah i
know might have a house like that i was
listening to it
[ __ ] your brow was like what's that
got to do with the house because
we could sneak we could just go into the
basement that's what i'm saying
yeah just like i've never been upstairs
at that house wow
i came in and out of the basement the
mom was she was working third shift or
what she was doing
but she wasn't around so we were in
there but i was all banged up to one
night
and i the sig was lit and i'm talking
you know trying to be funny whatever and
i
the sig somehow got twisted in my
fingers so i'm holding the lit sig
backwards [ __ ] i'm on the front deck
holding court dude
holding cool i think i'm johnny i feel
like zack morris
in the toga party episode and i got to
[ __ ] sing backwards
dude i it liter i felt i thought i
swallowed a bee dude my [ __ ] bad was
like what the [ __ ]
cherries flying everywhere it was a bad
bad scene bad scene burnt your mouth oh
yeah
anyway what was i saying yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] wrong with captain i've
done that smoking a joint like you
[ __ ] sucked a cherry in or something
like that yeah it's awful
it's so bad have you ever seen this i
haven't seen this in probably 20 years
but you ever seen someone get hit with
the exploding tip
what yeah like a [ __ ] cartoon no
who are you hanging out with johnny
knoxville
yeah what's the road runner like dude he
did some [ __ ] like that you were
fighting yeah did you ever get hit with
an anvil what
[Laughter]
you know it's what people fall for um
on the golf course is that exploding
golf ball that'll get people do you ever
see that
it's like chalk like a gender reveal no
it's like chalk
and it looks like and i've never i've
seen it
like on like videos and stuff what they
do is like they switch out the ball when
the guy's not looking
so when you hit it it just turns into a
big dust clutch you know what i mean
it's like
that'll get you i've seen that before
you have never seen rage like someone
who thinks they're about to just [ __ ]
cool out with a fat dart and just
[ __ ]
i don't even get that that seems
dangerous it's not safe
that's like those exploding those
candles that don't go out
i don't [ __ ] with dude if you brought
those to a party it was the last time
you were invited to the [ __ ] party
no trying to get my cake on dawg yeah
[ __ ] sitting here doing [ __ ]
childish pranks it's fire hazard let's
go
full full i can just imagine you lose it
as a kid like my wishes won't come true
[Laughter]
well my wish was to eat the cake so yeah
it wasn't
hemming me up ah
that's good [ __ ] that there had to have
been a
string of house fires in the 80s due to
the candles that won't go out
yeah for sure i mean yeah do you ever
see that this was back
on like not america's funniest videos it
wasn't that funny but like
most extreme or can't believe caught on
tape it was a firework
factory in like beijing or something man
talk about the fourth of july this thing
went up
and like they were like spraying hoses
they're like we just gotta let this
thing burn out
there was [ __ ] snakes roman k
everything was happening in that place
it was just popping
he did that one time at my buddy uh my
buddy's house
again his dad single parent dad cool dad
big house out in the middle of nowhere
like
you know like you had a dream it was
like 15 minutes outside of where i live
so it was even more like roar it was
rural rather than suburban you know
single dad he was always out we were
just always boozing and [ __ ]
somebody had fireworks so we're like oh
it's cool and they had they were
building a
uh pool house right yeah like cash or
building a pool house so it was just the
fount just the basement was poured
the foundation was poured of the pool
house it was just concrete
okay right so it was like concrete with
like a couple of rooms you know
um so we're like oh let's light it in
there like nothing's gonna catch fire or
whatever you know
so we like lit it in there and just it
was made of gunpowder
just as we lit it his dad came i don't
know what happened but his dad turned
the co as we were all running out of the
basement his dad turned the car like
what's going on folks
like get the deck [ __ ] dude he
started [ __ ] mortars and roman
candles flying by his head it was a
scene
had a [ __ ] lay-low there for a couple
of weeks
the party's there stopped real quick
catch you next summer
yeah out um he was also the guy that had
a kegerator with a locker they put a
lock on it
but there was like a little bit of
wiggle room in the lock so you could
like
pull the tap like a [ __ ] smidge you
got to really put
[ __ ] pressure on it and it would open
the valve
the slightest bit and we would fill up
pictures with it and it would take
like 40 minutes to fill up a picture
because it was just like really dripping
out so we would just [ __ ] do that go
hang
come back at a fresh [ __ ] fresh
pitcher of course or whatever
and i remember the it was like locked up
what he thought for like
three months like no one's ever touched
this and his dad was having a party
[ __ ]
everybody's coming over i got plenty of
courses yeah brand new keg it's been
locked did he open that up
it was pissed he had to have someone go
do a beer run for like 40 people
like they were all at the house that's
awesome tough luck
what i thought you're going to say
something oh no i don't know
[ __ ] going on a b-roll with a hand
truck is a tough look
we did we toby's got the goofies he is
he's like kids a little i got two hours
of sleep and i haven't eaten all day
i'm literally cutting myself out of this
entire episode i'm not even it's not a
joke
that too including right now uh it's
fine and we're back
this one came in on facebook and it was
pretty good they tagged i think they
might attack both of us but they tagged
me in it
uh and then we can wrap it up this is uh
from
trevine trevin treven okay um
blockbuster ever send your account to
collections
man do you ever get hemmed up on we
never got hemmed up bad with them
we we i know we got my mom was big on
not paying the fees we're not we're
getting this back
on time we've moved on from several
independent video stores
the old burning turn yeah it got to a
point
because what would happen would be like
there was never a problem if my mom and
dad went if my mom and dad went and we
went
together and we got [ __ ] goonies
raiders of the lost ark or whatever
they could go back they would make sure
that those cassettes were returned on
time
the problem was whenever they gave us
the liberty to be adults if you got
older
to go ourselves we would go and get
something
we'd take it to [ __ ] joey's house
i'll bring it joey
i didn't finish it i want to show my
brother now the case is gone the [ __ ]
the cassette's just by itself so we
would get hemmed up where there would be
notices or they'd be calling
hey you owe a hundred dollars for
[ __ ] weekend to bernie stew
my mom would just move on
to the next video store their repo in
your car over look who's talking now
they come and take your vcr you wake up
they're stealing your vco put a lock on
our vcr
yeah no we would just we would just keep
it moving yeah but i remember like that
stuff
that was like pant like in the top oh
they put a boot on top gun
tom cruise shows up hey what the [ __ ]
man
no okay fair enough he doesn't have to
uh i'll cut that for you too folding
i got a lot of work to do on this
episode man you're gonna be like edward
scissorhands
this episode's gonna be 15 minutes all
right let's wrap it up
gang listen we love you we will uh see
you next time kippy what do you got for
him guys as always we [ __ ] appreciate
the support
um and we're thinking of new reward
challenges for the patreon
uh so if you've got some ideas let us up
we're thinking a golf challenge
between the three of us thinking of the
are you garbage
invitational yeah maybe find a corset
will play ball
a couple of cameras we do we can go out
to flushing meadows pitch and putt
you know what since it's the
invitational maybe we should bring along
a couple special guests
wow play around the golf with us
obviously you meant comedians yeah oh
i thought you meant special guests like
fans
listeners yeah but then it's only it's
then that that sucks because if
somebody's in milwaukee
like sure so you're limiting sure the
pool of people
you know are able to do it there'll be
no airfare included yeah you can't be
like hey come on out to
get yourself to new york for five grand
and we'll play golf with you for an hour
that's not [ __ ] fair and then aisha
and lunch
you're picking up the beer cart too
right uh yes we'll figure something out
but i think that might be good a couple
of guys go out play around the golf
course beers couple of bernies couple of
bernies couple of beers nothing wrong
with it
i got a quick church announcement sure
church yeah that's kind of what it feels
like right the church bulletin board
okay not really but proceed go right
ahead mike i got that too man
i'm going to have my young christian
friend yeah come on down to holy savers
we got a new merch run coming up so if
you're a designer and you want to send
me some of your work just dim it to me
at toby.mcmullen we want to get involved
maybe a fan help us design some of these
yeah we're looking for some cool designs
uh so shoot them and uh you know you'll
obviously be compensated for your
pay for your work excellent if we
proceed with it that is
excellent don't be sending me a stick
figure and asking and a venmo request at
the same time can anybody submit to that
you cannot know okay fair enough
all right yeah all right let's go we
love you